The print line command is not only used to display text.
You can also print out the result of a calculation, for example.
Like this statement here, System.out.Println(2+3);
Notice that I didn't put any quotation marks
around this here because we don't want to display it as text.
We actually want the result of this mathematical calculation.
So, when we run this Java program here with those two statements,
the output we get is, Hello world!
just exactly as we typed it in here.
But then the second line is just 5,
which is the result of 2+3.
Notice how each one was printed in a separate line,
hence print line command and how the first one was displayed exactly as we typed it in,
while the second one was the result of the calculation.
Computers can do a lot more than just display a message on the screen.
Yep. They can make decisions and perform
calculations based on the information that we give them.
In fact, let me show you what a computer can do that us humans are terrible at.
Suzanne, do you want to play a game?
Sure. What game?
It's a memory game.
You might need to use these.
So imagine that there's this bus that starts off with no passengers on board
and then later on three passengers hop on and two passengers hop off.
Later on one more passenger hops on and no one hops off.
Later on another passenger hops on and another passenger hops off.
My question is how many stops did the bus make?
Oh, no, I wasn't keeping track of that.
I know. But you did a really good job keeping track of the passengers on the bus.
It's also interesting that you only needed one box to do that.
Yeah. That's because all I needed to keep track
of is just this one single number of passengers onboard.
I didn't really need to remember every single number you said.
True and that's exactly what a computer would have done as well. Let me show you how.